i started looking on the internet as one
does for time travel experiences
and i came across an internship at
worldpathpage and
part of what was promoted was that you
could do this history internship there
was a history internship and an acting
internship and history one was you could
live there for a period of time and
kind of become a character in the
village which very much appealed to me
i applied to both of them and somehow
got both of them so that's how i ended
up there that summer so you were living
there during that experience not at the
time that conan came but later on yeah
we got to stay there and
like stuff her own mattresses with straw
and milk the cow every morning and build
fires and bake bread and yeah it was
very you had to do it like you couldn't
do anything that wasn't in accord with
the time
so like the outhouse was the outhouse no
way it was wonderful
yeah and were you the same character
throughout the whole experience or were
you switching off when you guys came it
was the very very beginning of the
internship so we hadn't even started
doing the research to develop the
characters so that character was just
improvised for that day um and the
character that i ended up working on was
kind of a riff on that character yeah
who i was who i got to be every day and
were you aware of conan at all prior to
that shoot uh
not much i knew i
knew his name i knew he was on
television i don't think i'd ever watch
the program
i still don't on the tv so i'm yeah
i i knew he existed um but i didn't know
much about him what did they tell you
when they were actually coming to the
village like were you aware days ahead
of time i think it was just the night
before like the evening we were told
that he might be coming and that we
might be like background and what was
the energy at the village that day oh
very much excitement yeah people were
very excited and i um do i say this i'm
not sure you have to say it
i don't care
i don't know if that was a like i'm
going to not care like strategically not
care because i don't want to care or if
i really didn't i don't know so did they
just come take over with cameras i can't
remember at what point in the day it
occurred i think it was towards the end
of the day i remember there being a buzz
about it and then at some point we were
asked to come over because they were
possibly going to film the um baseball
team and what were your first thoughts
of conan when you saw him it was
marvelous i mean brilliant just so in
tune with everything that was going on
and able to respond to it yeah i had i
had no idea what to expect so that was
just such a pleasure to watch and you
have experience as a performer what was
it like performing with him like that
i'm uneasy with a sentence that i have
experienced as a performer but i love
theater and i had you know studied it as
a student the sense of play and
responsiveness was just very joyful yeah
i mean you killed it and you felt so uh
perfectly like in the character was that
difficult to stay kind of in that
reality yeah
i mean i think i think you can see their
moment so it's like oh that's
i'm laughing i'm laughing because he's
very funny and then try to try to get
back